Speaker 1: All right.
Listen, I think we're doing something good
today.
We talked about Biden's bribery.
We were going to talk now about Hillary's
emails.
We're going to talk about Joe Biden's classified
documents.
I think that while you and I mostly understand
that these are red herrings and what about
ism from the right, it's not a bad thing when
we have the opportunity to put on the record
everything we know about these situations
so we can refer back to it.
So I'm going to give you a couple of examples
here of incredible.
What about ism from right wingers?
Here is, for example, Ron DeSantis, interestingly
enough, defending Donald Trump against his
recent indictment by immediately bringing
up Hillary Clinton's emails.
I know it's satirical and almost a parody
at this point that you ask about a real 37
felony count indictment with pictures, with
evidence, with witnesses, and they say, well,
what about Hillary's emails for which she's
been cleared of criminal wrongdoing?
But that's what they want to do.
Here's Ron DeSantis.
Speaker 2: When I was in Congress, I remember,
you know, Hillary had the emails with the
classified.
And my view was, well, gee, you know, as a
naval officer, I was taken classified to my
apartment.
I would have been court martialed in a New
York minute.
And yet they seem to not care about that.
And is there a different standard for a Democrat
secretary of state versus a former Republican
president?
I think there needs to be one standard of
justice in this country.
Right.
Speaker 1: And that standard of justice is
if there is evidence of criminality, regardless
of who you are, you get yourself indicted.
It's actually sort of shocking that they're
still doing this.
And it's not just Ron DeSantis.
Here's another example.
Here's Republican Congressman Mike Waltz,
who, again, in an attempt to defend Trump,
says, listen, you can call it what about ism?
And then he brings up Hillary Clinton's email.
Speaker 2: Why not just hand them over?
If to your point, this happens a lot?
Yeah, well, look, if he believed he was privilege
under the Presidential Records Act, then that
is a conversation that I would argue should
have continued to happen.
Because what's missing also in this conversation,
and I can tell you this, talking to Floridians
and and folks back home, you can call it what
about what about ism?
Speaker 1: And we will because that's what
it is.
Speaker 2: What have you.
They're calling it fairness.
And there's legal precedent here.
When you have the Clinton tapes, when you
have the Clinton emails, when you have the
fact that the sitting national security adviser
right now, Jake Sullivan, was sending and
laundering classified documents into an unclassified
server on top of the fact that the sitting
president of the United States admitted he
had documents in his garage that you're going
in and out of, People look at that and say,
whoa, wait a minute.
There was prosecutorial discretion there.
They didn't prosecute.
They didn't go after these folks and all of
these other instances.
Speaker 1: All right.
You get the point.
This actually makes no sense, but sends in
the facts don't matter.
So it in a sense, makes perfect sense that
they are doing something that makes no sense.
Donald Trump's indictment is based on 37 felony
counts related to mishandling classified documents,
obstructing justice, making false statements.
Some of those actions under the Espionage
Act, which we will dig into later as we continue
our deep dive into this.
The Hillary Clinton email controversy was
based on allegations that she used a private
email server for public communications.
This was deemed extremely careless by the
FBI.
It was not deemed criminal by the FBI because
it did not appear to break the law.
That's what we care about.
The Trump indictment says Trump shared a classified
map related to military operations with people
who were not qualified to see that he knew
that it wasn't declassified because he said
after leaving office, this is classified.
He improperly stored boxes containing classified
documents by his toilet in the ballroom, in
the shower.
He went out of his way to avoid giving back
the documents.
He.
Hillary Clinton's email controversy involved
emails that were retroactively classified
by the State Department after they were sent
or received an important detail.
None of them were marked classified at the
time.
The Trump indictment alleges Trump got numerous
requests from the Justice Department saying,
Just hand this stuff over, hand it over, and
he didn't do it.
The allegations against Trump include making
false statements to the FBI, going to his
aides and lawyers and saying, help me lie,
help me hide, help me do everything to avoid
giving these documents back in the Hillary
Clinton situation.
She immediately and voluntarily handed over
about 30,000 emails to the State Department
that were work related and deleted, about
30,000 personal emails she deemed irrelevant.
The right likes to say, well, the 30,000 emails
she deemed irrelevant weren't irrelevant.
Okay.
Well, the investigation hasn't determined
that that's the case.
The Trump indictment could result in prison
time for him and Walton outA, who is a coconspirator
and was also indicted.
The Hillary Clinton email controversy was
fully investigated and the determination was
there was not a crime committed and so charges
were not filed.
The right says that's because of political
bias.
There is no evidence of that because the things
Hillary did and what Trump is accused of are
dramatically different.
So that's Hillary's emails.
Let's now look at the Joe Biden part a little
bit more closely.